it's 85 degrees in los angeles that
means it's time to get chilly
[Music]
oh no hi my name is grace helbig if you
do not know now you know your life is
different now welcome to another cooking
video
before we start quick story i got off to
use the bathroom in the middle of the
night the other night and i stood up
from the toilet so
quickly when i was done that i fainted
and i fell and slammed my shoulder
into my tub so if this shoulder looks
crazy
it's because it is and this arm's a
little defunct throughout the entirety
of this video is because it is but
that's not gonna stop me
from making some chili on a hot summer
day
everything about this makes sense
including the shoulder injury
and goose this is the time that goose
hydrates herself
so
all done okay a reminder to all of us to
hydrate you might not
faint when you stand up too quickly cool
news is that i tucked a sleeveless
sweater tank into a pair of jeans
fashion bloggers look out anyone can do
it
let's get started we are making one pot
pork and black bean chili oh oh
i have another camera over here haha i
never made this chili before but it
sounds great and on the hot day who
doesn't want
a big steaming pot of various
hot beans let's get our ingredients so
for those of you that don't know
hellofresh isn't america's number one
meal kit
we got to the end of that sentence and
they just keep allowing me to make
videos making their food and this time
around
it's gonna be extra precarious
no eggs i actually didn't check if
there's eggs no eggs
when you gamble you always win yeah
hello stuff
it's crazy how you guys just turned into
like a thing
that makes sense and has purpose oh
right now
you all are purposeless talking points
shall we we shall let's get to the
talking point damn it they're america's
number one meal kit meaning that they
have more five star reviews
than any other meal kit out there it
also helps you save time something that
we all need in quarantine
more time just more time to think about
what we've done
all of us a lot and you'll get that time
with america's number one meal kit they
offer 30 minutes as the average time
that it takes to make the meal and get
it on a plate 20 minutes if you use one
of their quick and easy recipes it's
sustainable all the ingredients are
pre-packaged so you only use exactly
what they give you
so there's less waste as someone who had
to take a sh in the middle of the night
that's what caused her to faint into her
tub
i'm a proponent of less waste and
they're very flexible
you can change your meal plans you can
change your meal delivery dates whenever
you want and they give back in 2019
hellofresh
gave over 2.5 million meals to different
charities and they plan on doing
even more this year during coronavirus
during the pandemic they're helping out
so you can feel good about supporting
them
those are all the points and you know
what comes after points a break
point break never saw it but that's a
thing
huh isn't it weird that people that have
never actually seen
movies still understand when they hear
popular titles that they
exist but people that have never like
seen someone with kovid just
doesn't want to believe that it exists
[Music]
and tom hanks got it let's start making
this meal every hellofresh recipe comes
with just six steps
six times that you can it all
up that's amazing wash and dry produce
half peel and dice the onion where's my
knife what did borat say
in the kitchen my knife that looks
pretty clean so because of this
shoulder thing i got some medically
prescribed
ibuprofen which is fairly strong so
i'm feeling pretty good today also if
you want to hear the full story about it
listen to the podcast i do with my
friend mamrie heart
this might get weird i talk about it all
over there so glad i got this second
camera angle going
so important you can't see that from
there but from there huh
you're spoiled thinly slice half the
jalapeno
into rounds and then we mince the other
half oh
remove the ribs and seeds first if you
want it less spicy
i want it less spicy i wanted boring
bland i want missionary level spice
you're yeah i don't know what level of
quarantine you're at but i'm in the
playfully shaming my food level
half of this gets little slices
and then the other half gets fully diced
is
wash your hands and we're on the step
two heat a large drizzle of
oil in a medium pot over medium high
heat drizzle
what they call the quirky home eq
teacher that like to take you inside all
kinds of recipes
miss drizzle we're gonna add our onion
and jalapeno and season with salt and
pepper and then we cook
stirring for five to seven minutes this
is so easy it's always getting up from a
toilet and walking back to bed they said
what do you guys have been up to
i'm gonna try and guess something that
at least one of you might have possibly
done
slow dance with a stranger over zoom did
someone do that
you know what's crazy i've heard this
from other people but it's true
if you think about it someone's done it
if you think about anything
possible someone's done it we're doing
it there's two people out there over
zoom
right now both eating hot pockets at
least they both
are doing something with hot pockets oh
the pork shoot
me i forgot to uh forgot to defrost my
pork so we're just gonna
quickly defrost the pork as they say and
then get back to cooking everyone calm
down
we're not ready the pork is not ready we
cannot consummate a meal until the pork
is ready
pork's ready now we're on to step three
we're going to add the pork
mexican spice southwest spice salt and
pepper to
the pot and we're gonna cook that all
together for four to six
minutes while breaking up the meat
that's the only break up
i like breaking up the meat endless pork
mexican spice southwest spice salt and
pepper
then we cook that breaking up the meat
for four to six minutes let's do it
now we're socially distant cute
that meat is gonna need some gassy foods
and the subtle attention of someone
they've always thought was attractive
because it is fully broken up back there
we're on the step four over halfway
there we're gonna stir in some tomato
paste
and cook for another one to two minutes
let's do it no your diced tomatoes
oh my god that would have been [ __ ]
day oh [ __ ] i found this tomato paste
it's all kinds of thick and stubborn no
wonder i couldn't find it
tomato paste yes tomato paste cooks for
a minute or so now we're going to add
the
diced tomatoes you little foods diced
tomatoes the beans
and their juices go into the meal that's
a sentence you loved it here
that concentrate a fourth cup of water
i'm using this to measure
liquids i know i'm not supposed to but
if you think i'm wrong you can just very
politely eat
a dick salt and pepper we bring to a
simmer and we cook uncovered until
thickened for eight to ten minutes
i'm going to get these hot beans in my
bod
my body is a temple and meals looking
like that prove it while
the chili cooks let's work on our crema
in a small bowl
oh gosh you are so small the bowl is
doing an impression of women
and i was doing an impression of society
we're gonna combine our sour cream
that is just what you do that's your
special skill
that's your party trick just bordering
out of all kinds of packages
we're going to mine our hot sauce then
we're going to add salt and pepper and
some
water until we get it to a consistency
that can be drizzled you know that
quirky oh my teacher i'm talking about
miss drizzle all right now i just let
the chili cook until it's all kinds of
thick and ready to serve and then we're
gonna plate it up
cooking it can happen
at any time to anyone all right it's
basically done cooking it looks pretty
yeah so that means it's time to plate it
up
[Music]
like that's their dating profile photo
and like this is how they look when they
show up and you're all like you should
wear a mask and they're all like you
know what
you're absolutely right i'm sorry i was
being a selfish little [ __ ]
i think we got pretty close we did it we
made one
ah we made one pot black bean chili look
at this we did it oh
god this is just a big old bowl of farts
and i cannot
wait it's gonna have a great time down
there before i try this as always you
guys get a special gift
if you want to try out hello fresh this
month you get 80
off with purchase including free
shipping on your first box if you go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
hellbig80 again 80
off with purchase free shipping on your
first box
if you use hellbig80
okay let's taste this thing do i like
chili i don't know we're gonna find out
oh hot i'm very hot and delicious wow
it's got substance oh no
that's really good for how quick it was
usually doesn't chili have to sit
like on a stove for like three weeks and
then finally the flavors have all melted
together like if they're not gonna meld
in like 30 minutes
it's like speed dating moving along
anyway this is delicious and i think we
did a really good job
let's get a second opinion like the
framing is perfect for you see how
better it can be when
you're not in the fridge has decided
right now is the time as always to drink
nicely you involve me thank you for
making me a part of it and
any thoughts seems great okay it's very
good okay
thank you so much that's it guys i hope
you enjoyed this video if you did
i guess give it a thumbs up subscribe to
this channel this content
when it happens other than that i don't
know
totally chill shoulders